mark give us your assessment what is the
Greek situation really like right now
well my sense is that they will come to
some kind of an agreement in the last
minute but I don't think that any
positive because Greece is basically
bankrupt the death should be written
down by 50% two more however out this to
say I don't believe that stocks are
going down because of Greece I believe
that the market has been weakening
internally for a long time on friday
there were almost 200 new 12 month
clothes on the new york stock exchange
the Chinese stock market the shanghai
index is now down twenty percent from
the high so great is a tight play but
it's used by people as an excuse to sell
stock mark should people in europe feel
confident that what's happening in
Greece stays in greece or do you think
we could see contagion spread and
similar concerns ria rise in spain and
italy well i think a lot of Europeans
don't like the EU and the bureaucrats in
Brussels they hate them because the
bureaucrat in Brussels are like the IMF
and the World Bank basically a corrupt
organization that do not pay taxes but
then impose taxes on other people and
divorced and I strongly believe that the
typical European would prefer not to
have or be member of the EU mark I want
to get your perspective on who and if I
what I mean what kind of investor is
going to profit the most off this
weakness that we're seeing this morning
brought on by the Greek debt crisis
brought on by the negative
headlines on Puerto Rico brought on by
the sulphur China what kind of investor
I will tell you precisely the investor
who are in cash they benefit the most
because asset prices have come down
substantially in the last couple of
weeks in the case of China within two
weeks the market is found twenty percent
the bomb the market has given up all the
game since the beginning of the year and
their loss is in bombed so people who
are in cash they're not totally wrong
and the big losers are people who just
bought on the advice of some media into
stocks a month ago they are the big
losers because many stocks micro nice
town forty-six percent from its high
earlier this year the many stocks that
have lost a lot of money mark besides
cash is there anything else that you
like right now yes I like my Bloomberg
terminal no I feel like precious metal
they may still come under some pressure
who knows but in general the gates the
world is indebted and the best version
is so high that there won't be any
substantial economic growth now Japan
with AB anomic they just reported for me
that the industrial production was down
two percent so money printing doesn't
solve all the problem money printing
doesn't solve all the problems yet China
is trying to do what it can to bolster
its economy we heard about the interest
rate cut the surprise cut over the
weekend what is your interpretation of
that move was it aimed at keeping the
rally going was it aimed at addressing a
liquidity shortage my friend is that
the Chinese economy has weakened varies
substantially the stock market went up
from a year ago by more than a hundred
percent I have maintained that the
market would correct at least forty
percent I think we're down twenty
percent I think another twenty percent
is likely but longer term as you know
the US since 1802 today have so many
recessions and the civil war and world
wars and the worse and worse still right
I'm still reasonably optimistic that the
Chinese economy after a slump will come
out okay but they need a lesson in terms
of borrowing less in terms of reducing
deaths and leveraged up to all the other
countries too but you are assigned
following the 2008 crisis the central
bank allows governments to borrow even
more because of their artificial no
interest rate so basically global dates
of the percent of global gdp up 30
descend from the 2007 level right right
right we're not gonna end well that's
for sure hmm whether Greece is the
catalyst who knows but definitely the
market are reacting on the downside and
largely because corporate earnings will
disappoint first of all wages are going
up they will squeeze corporate profits
number two interest rates won't go much
lower so as they don't go any lower it
also squeezes corporate profits and
number three the most important economy
for emerging markets was China and China
is now growing at maximum three to four
percent per annum three to four percent
per annum according to marc faber so
given all that mark do we presume that
the federal reserve is unable to move
ahead with its September timetable for
an interest rate increase
it's matthew the Fed under the dovish
mrs. Yellen will not increase interest
rate for a very long time and if they do
it will be by an eighth of a quarter
percent just to see what the market
reaction is but I personally doubt she
will do it this year they'll find an
excuse not to do it but should they I
mean one of the unintended consequences
of keeping rates where they are if the
US economy is doing well shouldn't we
focus on that or shouldn't she excuse me
do you really think that the US economy
is doing well I thought not my
impression i think the typical household
is squeezed very badly I was recently in
a limousine and then we talked about
this and that and the limousine driver
told me his health care premium what is
having the insurance premium this year
will go up thirty-nine percent so I
believe that actually most households of
struggling but they're borrowing money
again most households in the US have no
savings I believe that the US economy
will badly disappoint within six months
mark do you just carry an umbrella all
day every day just always rains in marks
town mark thank you so much for joining
us this morning gonna nordmark father
he's the editor a loon we have a
shortage of rain we have a crowd well
mark I love when you join us these mark
father is a yak executive editor of
gloom boom & doom report